Speaker 1: Let's go to this week's mailbag.
Always glad to get emails and messages from
people.
Mostly glad.
Anyway, I guess I can't say always, but generally
speaking you can email info at David Pakman
dot com if you have something to say.
Keep it polite, keep it quick, keep it substantive
and many things this week meeting those requirements.
Not all.
Let's start with a couple of wacky your message.
No B.S. wrote in and said without any evidence.
I should add, you were paid by the Democrats
to spread disinformation and lies with no
shame.
No wonder you come from one of the most corrupt
countries in the world.
That's a reference to Argentina.
Argentina is very corrupt.
That's true.
You lied and lied since 2016.
It started with Trump Russia when it was proven
recently.
It was all a hoax.
That's not true.
You didn't even admit it.
Satan is all over you, but judgment day will
come.
I don't care about your religious nonsense
but prove I'm paid by the Democrats.
That's most of this is not the most of these
are not even empirical statements we can't
even I mean, you know, Satan will one day
unleash judgment day upon me.
Neither one of us will ever know that.
But there's a specific claim that I'm paid
by the Democrats.
Let's assume they mean the Democrats.
Prove it.
I would incur you know, every day.
David, you're paid by the Democrats.
David, you're paid by George Soros.
Soros You guys know about that, right?
Prove it is my request to you.
Thank you very much.
Jason wrote in and said Your show sucks ass.
The little remarks you make during a Trump
rally are idiotic.
You chime in on the.
Speaker 5: Tiniest things.
Speaker 1: Trump says, but the big facts you
completely ignore Shut up and listen and don't
interrupt.
Perhaps you just shouldn't cover his rallies.
Studied that.
Duggar studied it to debtor.
You are a tiny little man that hides behind
a microphone.
You should try.
Maybe play by play for the NHL, maybe.
Oh, I would love to do that.
Thank you.
Now that it's a completely unhinged message,
at first I don't know if you're making fun
of me for a stutter I don't have or I know
lots of people on the right have been making
fun of Joe Biden for having a stutter.
I don't know anything about the stutter part,
but I would be totally up for doing some sports
play by play.
I think it would be an incredible thing to
learn.
And Jason, listen, if you can help get me
in, I would love to do that.
On the weekends, Brett wrote in about Tulsi
Gabbard and says, Tulsi maintains that the
leaker was trying to interfere with the normal
Supreme Court process.
Isn't that the same as what the peaceful protesters
were trying to do on January six?
Right.
Well, no, because they you have to remember,
Bret, the January six protesters just wanted
to make sure there was no fraud and okay.
They wanted to prevent the election from being
certified, but that would have been wrong
then or something.
And then the Supreme Court leaker was doing
something wrong, even though no crime was
committed there.
But 700 people have been accused of crimes
related to the Trump brides.
Don't worry about any of that, Brett.
Just listen to Tulsi.
She'll always tell you the truth.
I'm sure I got a message about my interest
rate segment.
Which said Pete wrote in and said, You said
to let you know if the interest rate hike
segment was useful.
And I just wanted to say it was very useful.
CNN and MSNBC have explained it that straightforward.
Please keep educating us.
You're good at explaining things.
Thank you, Pete.
Well, I really appreciate that.
And like I said, those segments, almost no
one watches them, but I enjoy doing them.
And the people that do watch them seem to
get a lot out of them.
So we'll we'll keep doing it.
I have no problem with that whatsoever.
Let's go to our next e-mail.
This one is from John about strengthening
of the dollar.
John says, David, sir, I had a quick question
about strengthen the dollar.
I'm a union member and recently had a conversation
with an older woman that's also a union member.
And she mentioned the phrase strengthen the
dollar, which I honestly, I'm not 100% sure
what that means.
But I told her, so if you work the next six
months straight with our wages, how does that
affect you personally?
And she had that deer in the headlights look
on her face.
Literally, her eyebrows went up quite funny
because she looked so shocked then.
Didn't have an answer, literally said she
didn't know.
Funny thing is, I don't really know the significance
of that either.
I've just learned to ask why.
I also have a friend that is mid-forties.
During a conversation, he said something about
Biden weakening the dollar.
Now this friend is on disability and doesn't
work.
So I asked him, why does that matter to you?
No offense, but you're on disability and I'm
pretty sure you'll be fine.
Yes, that that is generally true.
And I don't honestly know about that either,
but I also don't think it would.
But he said the same thing, a pause and then
I don't know.
So, okay, here's the deal with the strength
of the dollar stuff.
As a general principle, when people say a
stronger dollar, they mean the dollar is worth
more relative to other currencies.
So there is a crazy situation right now where
the dollar nominally is now worth more or
it's almost equivalent to the euro.
The value of the dollar has increased significantly
over the last year and a half relative to
the euro.
So number one is a lot of people who talk
about strengthening of the dollar don't even
really know how it would help them.
The way it would help is it would make imports
relatively less expensive, all else being
equal.
Okay.
The funniest part is a lot of the people saying
strengthen the dollar don't know that the
dollar is much stronger now than it has been
in a while.
And I'm not even saying Biden gets the credit
for that.
I'm just saying it is.
And many people extraordinarily confused.
So, John, you did a great thing, which is
you asked specific questions.
How would that affect you?
And they don't know.
That doesn't mean it wouldn't affect them.
They just have no idea why, which is basically
just as funny.
Douglas wrote in about refuting election conspiracy
theorists and said, Many Republican candidates
you interview assert that the election was
stolen.
None are ever specific on how such a conspiracy
could have been carried out in multiple states.
One who directed the conspiracy to how many
people were involved and at what levels?
Three.
Why have there been no whistleblowers?
Well, they would say that there have been.
They would say the affidavits are whistleblowers.
Instead, they Gish Gallop and regurgitate
Mike Pillow's talking points about how many
votes were stolen in what states can you please
hold their feet to the fire about the specifics
of the conspiracy itself.
I'm going to try to do a better job on that.
These are all good questions.
They will what you have to remember is it's
really common to come across something like
this and think this is bulletproof.
When they start spouting, you just say who
directed it?
How many people were involved and why have
there been no whistleblowers?
And they will tell you with a straight face,
we don't even know the full scope of who directed
it, but it was Democrats as well as Antifa,
you know, whatever.
They'll have an answer.
And when you say how many people were involved,
they'll say it could be thousands of people.
And then you'll say, well, why have there
been no whistleblowers?
And they'll say, There have been.
Look at all of the affidavits that were brought
forward.
And then you have to say, well, but affidavits
aren't evidence in a strict sense, and you're
in the weeds.
So never underestimate their ability to put
you in the weeds, no matter what sort of refutation
you offer.
Koop wrote in and said, Hey, David, sorry,
buddy, but the facial hair isn't a good look
for you.
My opinion only.
So take it for what it's worth.
I will, Coop.
Thank you.
I'm going to take it for nothing.
That's how much it's worth to me.
I just.
This is not a big deal, guys.
Climate change, invasion of Ukraine.
Roe v Wade overturned weaponized Trump ism.
My facial hair is very, very low on the list
of priorities.
But Koop does say Keep up the good work, which
I appreciate.
I appreciate that.
Thank you.
Dan wrote in and said, Cultural Marxists.
I love this with the question mark.
It's great.
David, greatly appreciate your work and was
wondering if I could get your thoughts on
the cultural Marxists phrase that gets thrown
around by the right.
Even a British conservative politician used
it recently.
It seems interchangeable with postmodernism
woke mob, political correctness, critical
race theory.
And is it possibly means little?
But it's just a scary term the right uses
to reference something bad.
I'd be interested in your help.
Many thanks, Dan.
Yes.
So cultural Marxism is another right wing
conspiracy theory.
It has a bit of an anti-Semitic twist.
The idea is that cultural Marxism is a philosophy
or worldview that will wreck and destroy American
culture and American morality.
As right wingers see it, pop cultural Marxism
can be thought of as a sort of political correctness
on steroids.
It's an assault on the American way of life
now in its original form.
The idea here is that there's a group of Jewish
philosophers who fled Germany in the 1930s,
went to teach at Columbia University, and
came up with this form of Marxism that is
focused on American culture.
It's you might think, well, Marxism is an
economic philosophy or a political philosophy.
No.
The idea is these Jewish individuals who fled
Germany in World War Two era came.
Came to the U.S. and said, we are going to
use Marxism on American culture.
And that's the kind of anti-Semitic element,
which oftentimes the people talking about
cultural Marxism are also very suspicious
and concerned about the role of Jews in American
culture.
And it's what it means today to people who
even know what they mean by it, and some of
them don't.
They mean that Jewish Marxists or left wing
Marxists are going to invade American culture
by taking over media systems, education, schools,
universities, etc., and do bad things.
And it's all going to be terrible is more
or less the the gist of it.
So that's cultural Marxism.
You can essentially I mean, listen, I'm not
saying ignore everything anyone says when
they use the phrase cultural Marxism, but
when someone says cultural Marxism unironically,
it should definitely be a red flag for you
that you should really carefully scrutinize
everything that this person is saying.
Send in your emails if you'd like to be featured
in next week.
Info at David Pakman ICOM Monday, May 30th.
We'll be doing a one day membership special
to commemorate Memorial Day.
You can get on our newsletter at David Pakman
dot com.
And then Monday Memorial Day, you'll get an
email telling you how to take advantage of
this great membership special.
We will see you on the bonus day today.